Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Equilibrio.
Equilibrio è una parola bellissima,
che indica armonia;
ma cosa significa nei contesti naturali?
In natura esiste una regola:
si tende sempre all'equilibrio,
dopo un cambiamento.
E questo equilibrio, però,
è qualcosa di dinamico, non è statico.
Il ritorno del lupo sulle Alpi
è un bellissimo esempio
che indica delle nuove dinamiche
dopo un cambiamento,
un cambiamento naturale:
appunto, il ritorno
di un grande predatore.
E queste dinamiche evolvono,
e si stanno evolvendo
alla ricerca di un equilibrio,
sia da un punto di vista ecologico
che da un punto di vista sociale.
Ecco, vorrei affrontare con voi
entrambe le questioni questa sera,
arrivando a riflessioni anche etiche.
Il lupo diciamo era presente in Europa,
in Nord America, sulle Alpi
fino agli inizi del 1900;
e poi ha riscontrato
delle decrescite un pochino ovunque
dovute a diversi fattori,
ad esempio la mancanza di territori,
la mancanza di prede;
ma soprattutto, una forte intolleranza
da parte dell'uomo.
Tanto che, all'inizio del 1900,
il lupo è stato completamente
estirpato, sulle Alpi.
Oggi si sta assistendo a un nuovo ritorno.
Il lupo sta ritornando in modo naturale
sulle Alpi, in Europa, in Nord America;
ma perché?
Perché ci sono, di nuovo,
le condizioni ecologiche
a supportarne la presenza:
foreste, prede, prede selvatiche.
Ma soprattutto,
abbiamo di nuovo una cultura
verso l'ambiente,
generalizzata,
che ne può supportare la presenza
anche da un punto di vista sociale.
Non vorrei esagerare con la parola
cultura, sull'ambiente,
perché sicuramente ci sono ancora
tantissimi miti da sfatare:
uno dei tanti  è quello
che racconta lupi ritornati in alcune zone
perché paracadutati
da elicotteri, da aerei.
Che poi, ve lo immaginate il lupo
che si mette il paracadute?
O tanto di più che se
lo toglie, quando atterra?
Insomma, il lupo è ancora oggi
al centro di bufale;
ma soprattutto è al centro
di un equilibrio ecologico e sociale
che vorrei vedere insieme a voi.
Parliamo prima di quello
che è l'equilibrio ecologico.
Questa è una foto dello Yellowstone,
un parco nazionale in Nord America:
io ho lavorato lì, e poi ho lavorato
anche per tanti anni, per 25 anni,
proprio sullo studio del ritorno
del lupo sulle Alpi,
ho seguito tutta
la ricolonizzazione naturale.
Ebbene vorrei portarvi
delle differenze che ci sono
proprio tra i sistemi altamente naturali,
come questo qua dello Yellowstone,
e casa nostra qui.
Quindi, partiamo dallo Yellowstone:
anche in questa zona il lupo
era stato estirpato completamente,
nel 1995 è stato reintrodotto.
Che cosa si è visto?
Ha avuto dell'eccezionale,
questa reintroduzione:
neanche ci si aspettava,
soprattutto sulla rapidità.
Praticamente, la popolazione di cervi
era molto abbondante in queste zone,
sovrabbondante.
Il lupo, appena arrivato, cosa ha fatto?
Ha iniziato a predare
la popolazione di cervi,
che sono diminuite.
Sono diminuite, ma hanno anche cambiato
quello che si dice
l'utilizzo del territorio,
proprio per un migliore
comportamento anti-predatorio.
E così è diminuito l'impatto
che i cervi avevano, essendo diminuiti,
su delle parti di foreste,
su degli alberi, su dei pioppi,
su dei salici eccetera,
che hanno potuto rifiorire, diciamo.
E a questo punto sono tornate
anche, di conseguenza,
tutte delle altre specie di uccelli,
di rapaci, tra cui il castoro.
E tra l'altro, avendo di nuovo
dei sistemi vegetali intorno ai fiumi,
gli stessi fiumi hanno avuto
dei diversi livelli di erosione,
cambiando un pochino il corso.
Si dice, forse in maniera
un pochino esagerata,
che il ritorno del lupo,
nello Yellowstone,
ha cambiato il corso dei fiumi;
be', questo forse è un po’ troppo,
perché vedete che cosa c'è in mezzo.
C'è un intero ecosistema interconnesso,
dove ovviamente il ritorno
di un super predatore
ha cambiato tutta una cascata trofica
che ha fatto sì che si riequilibrasse,
però in modo migliore.
Bene.
Detto questo, cosa succede qua
a casa nostra sulle Alpi?
La grossa differenza
è che non è il lupo a cambiare
il corso dei fiumi, da noi;
da noi è l'uomo, che cambia
il corso dei fiumi.
Noi viviamo in un sistema
fortemente antropocentrico,
infatti si parla di antropocene,
come era, quella di adesso;
e soprattutto, qua in Europa
il livello delle attività antropiche
è molto alto, anche in montagna.
Quindi abbiamo: foreste
che vengono tagliate;
sicuramente un altissimo turismo;
abitazioni; pastorizia;
caccia; presenza di cani;
comunque tutti fattori antropici presenti
che quindi si trovano,
ovviamente devono arrivare
a trovarsi in equilibrio
con il sistema preda-predatore
in atto in questo momento,
e con tutto l'ecosistema.
È quindi fondamentale, oggi,
pensare a tutte le attività antropiche
nell'ottica della
sostenibilità ambientale.
Vedete che le ho disegnate tutte verdi?
Perché?
Perché dobbiamo riuscire ad avere
delle attività che si dicono green
per quanto richiede l'agenda 2030.
Insomma, diminuire l'impatto antropico
per riuscire ad arrivare
a un equilibrio ecologico,
insieme al lupo e a tutto l'ecosistema.
Questa è la grossa sfida, oggi.
Passiamo all'equilibrio sociale.
Quando il lupo torna,
iniziano i conflitti:
i conflitti con l’uomo,
i conflitti sociali.
Principalmente in relazione
alla pastorizia,
perché il lupo se riesce
preda pecore, capre.
Quindi, quando il lupo torna l'allevatore
deve adattarsi a una presenza.
E la prima cosa da fare, sicuramente,
è utilizzare sistemi
di prevenzione che funzionano,
come l'utilizzo di reti elettrificate,
cani da guardiania;
ma soprattutto, la presenza
dell'allevatore.
Tutto questo implica lavoro aggiuntivo,
che non viene vissuto in un modo sereno,
anche perché implica maggiore lavoro,
implica un cambiamento,
un adattamento di abitudini
e viene richiesto
a un mondo rurale, statico,
e quindi è molto difficile
l'accettazione del lupo,
che viene vista come una figura
totalmente scomoda.
Inoltre il lupo viene spesso associato
a favole, a leggende
che promuovono la paura.
Il lupo non è pericoloso per l'uomo,
però ha questa fortissima connotazione
che spesso viene utilizzata
sia dai mass media
ma anche, magari, a livello
politico, locale, eccetera.
Tutto questo aumenta il conflitto,
che non è un bene non solo
per la conservazione del lupo,
ma anche per chi, quotidianamente,
deve convivere col lupo
e non vive in modo sereno questa presenza.
La parola chiave della ricerca
dell'equilibrio sociale
è coesistenza, o convivenza;
e per sviluppare la coesistenza
e necessaria la conoscenza.
E la conoscenza, l'aumento
della conoscenza,
diminuisce l'ignoranza e anche la paura.
Considerate
che ciò che non si conosce si teme,
e ciò che si teme si distrugge.
Quindi, l'unica via
verso un nuovo equilibrio
è quella data dall'aumento di conoscenza,
dall'aumento di mentalità
critiche sul tema,
che possono contrastare la paura.
In conclusione: il lupo,
il ritorno del lupo qua sulle Alpi,
ci mette alla prova,
perché è un'immagine iconica.
Tutti quanti abbiamo già
un immaginario individuale sul lupo,
basato magari su favole, su storie.
È difficile non avere già
un'opinione su questo animale.
Quindi vi chiedo, e mi chiedo,
proprio un esercizio:
l'esercizio di provare a vedere
quali sono i vostri pregiudizi
già su questa specie,
senza averla magari conosciuta a fondo;
riconoscere questi pregiudizi;
e a questo punto,
cercare nuove informazioni
oggettive, scientifiche,
magari anche personali,
e dirette, con la specie,
e lasciarsi lo spazio
per un atteggiamento critico
su questo tema.
Guardate che se riusciamo a fare
questo esercizio sul lupo
lo possiamo fare
anche con tantissimo altro.
Ed è per questo che la convivenza
tra uomo e lupo, oggi sulle Alpi,
è una bellissima prova
per la nostra società.
Grazie.
(Applausi)